all right it's 5 42 you know for the
parents of young kids finding ways to
keep them busy can be a task especially
in the summertime when they're hanging
around the house toys though well
they're very enjoyable it's better than
just being plugged into your screen
we're talking toys this morning and not
just for the kids so joining us now the
editor-in-chief for the toy Insider Ali
mirjesky thank you so much for coming in
early this morning thank you for having
me so you guys are having this big
showcase and we were able to kind of
grab a couple of these items I am so
excited about this right here I've been
talking about it for a week because this
is for older people as well definitely
so this is for kids ages five and up
this is Pictionary air 2. so what's
gonna happen is we're gonna hook up our
devices here this is a real AI high-tech
Pictionary game okay with that pen
you're going to be able to draw in the
air it'll show up on this screen for all
of your family to watch and we'll go
through all of the clues as you draw I'm
gonna give it a little demo there
if I'm just drawing here I'm just gonna
make a yeah
I know hold on I'm gonna get this right
there's a star okay I have some work to
do folks
really scribbles I know maybe that was
the word scribble okay Heather's gonna
work on this one but I love this um real
quick what's the price point on this
this is 22.99 easy breezy all right so
tonight we're next to get some balloons
it looks like yeah so this is the bunch
of balloons Tropical Party as you can
see they're very fun and neon what is
great about this is kids can inflate a
hundred water balloons for their water
balloon fight in 60 seconds so this end
just hooks right up to the hose or to a
sink even then they just slide them
right off their self-sealing and they're
ready to have a water balloon fight oh
my gosh okay wait a second John and I
love both these
so is this here this is the uh wooden
cool Scoops ice Creamery from Melissa
and Doug you know Melissa and Doug has
classic wooden toys so it's got all
kinds of fun accessories kids can build
ice cream sandwiches they can scoop
their ice cream into the cones we have
an order a tablet over here of course a
credit card that they can pay with as
we're learning about being consumers
this is great that's a little Magna
doodle as well that they can draw in so
this is so cute and perfectly summer
this kind of stuff when I was a kid you
know food but obviously it's come a
million you know years and I think
what's cool about all of this obviously
the Pictionary is a little different
here but there's no screens here there's
no strings it's all it's so much more
organic and just you can touch it in
Texas definitely all right so what's
this here with this this was going to
get outside getting that dirt right
old-fashioned summer and dirty this is
the nature fun gardening tool set it's
perfectly sized for kids ages four and
up so they can help out in the garden so
we're gonna teach them early how to
garden they can plant flowers and
vegetables grow their own food so that's
really fun but not too heavy but
definitely you know still sturdy
definitely durable and plus you get a
little helper outside as well right or
mess maker depending
and lastly we have a perfect travel toy
down here these are the cocomelon
hugmees the Coca melon of course is
super popular with our little ones these
are squishy and cuddly plush if you want
to pick one up
and they're just definitely they're
perfect for travel they got a little
yeah their little weight to them you
know to give her Comfort I guess again
just an idea of some prices of folks at
home they want to buy some stuff for the
kids for the summertime uh broadly what
kind of price point yeah so uh this is
about 27.99 our cocoa melon and our
bunch of balloons are both under ten
dollars and our Melissa and Doug set
here is 119.99 excellent that's such
this is fun stuff for all different ages
thank you so much for coming thank you
for having me all right uh sure we're
just gonna keep playing with some toys
over here if you want to do the weather
I mean John we're just gonna John grab
grab the balloons grab the balloons come
on we need them water balloon fight
after the show Absolutely